hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be going over the outlet variation which
stems from the Sicilian defense Sicilian
defense is pawn to e4 pawn to c5 you've
probably seen this this is one of the
most common defenses in all of chess
because it really gives black a fighting
chance there's a lot of sharp variations
Black has a lot of different ways that
he can actually take the initiative in
the game so a lot of top players GM's
club level players will play this not
only because it gives them an
opportunity to draw but there's so many
different ways for black to take over
the game and actually win the game so a
lot of white players actually don't play
efore because they're afraid of pawn to
c5 so today I'm going to be going over a
different variation that I recommend
it's kind of the anti Sicilian attack
from white most most times you'll see
you know Knight to f3 you'll see pawn to
d4 these are things that black wants to
see because it allows them to go into
their sharp variations that most of them
have studied up on but the aliping
variation is just pawn to c3 and it
tries to do two things one the out pin
variation tries to take away all the
initiative that black wants to gain in
the game so that's very very important
to get your opponent out of their
comfort zone is extremely important the
second thing is white really wants to
gain control of this d4 square right
here very very important in chess
especially in the Sicilian defense of
black playing pawn to c5 really wants to
gain control of this square without even
using his center pawn so very very
important again this is the anti
Sicilian and this is used by many many
of the greatest chess minds of all time
many GM's world champions if you've seen
this series that we did on casbah versus
deep blue in 1996 the first game deep
blue beat Kasparov and then the second
game because far-off came back and used
the ala pin variation to beat deep blue
so it's very very strong and you see it
all levels of chess now in this video
we're going to be going over the five
most common moves that you'll see from
black and then a lot of different
variations within those so you kind of
have a good idea of how to play this
what different things you should be
looking for and kind of how to approach
it but again
going back to the original things we're
just trying to take back the initiative
this is going to transition nicely into
the middle game and it's really going to
take away all the Sicilian variations
that blacks really used to so the first
move we're going to be going over is
Knight to f6 right here and black shirts
going to continue to push forward and
just attack that night with pawn to e5
now black has a lot of different ways he
can move right now as you can tell
Knight just going right back to g8 is
going to be a mistake it really gives
even more initiative to white right now
you never really want to be moving your
Knights back as far as you know
developing them and then moving them
back to the 8th or first rank so that's
going to be a mistake
you can tell that Knight to h5 is going
to be a mistake the Queen's going to
take and that really goes along with
Knight comes down to g4 that's going to
be a mistake it's also going to be a
mistake if he brings his knight down to
e4 all white has to do now is just you
know kick his pawn up to d3 right now
the knight no longer has anywhere to go
he's going to be taken he can't come
back to d6 f6 right here again if he
tries to come over here to g5 or g3 he's
going to be taken by either a bishop or
a pawn so that's going to be a mistake
so as you can tell the only really move
that black has is to bring his knight
over to d5 so from here
White's just going to play pawn to d4
now black does have a few options from
here the first one that you'll see is
just with black taking right here on d4
now white can take back right away but
he doesn't necessarily have to first
whites actually going to develop his
knight here to f3 and that's because
he's not really worried about this pawn
coming down to C 3 because this pawn was
blocking this night here on d5 so you
don't have to worry about getting that
material back you're going to get it
back eventually but you don't need to go
you know right away you can go ahead and
bring your knight over here to f3 first
so the Knights going to come right here
now black has the decision to make but
let's say he brings his knight over here
to b6 or c6 simple development move
trying to control the zoom on the board
protecting one of his pawns right now
then Y can go ahead and
now again what do we want to control the
CERN the board with you always want to
control the CERN the board with your
pawns and then you have your minor
pieces protect those pawns especially in
the early game now to move into the
middle game and in game those things
change but early on
you control the CERN the board with your
pawns so when you're thinking about
which piece you're going to take with is
it going to be the knight it's going to
be the pawn we're definitely going to be
taking back with our pawn pawns
controlling the sin of the board so from
right now as you can tell in this
variation that we've got over White has
a very very firm foundation in the
center of the board
you know this anti Sicilian this is not
Sicilian at all from blacks perspective
you know very very well developed this
Knight here on F 3 is both defending
both of these pawns right here and it's
very very nicely gaining control of the
center of the board so that is what
happens if that pawn takes here on we
come back here to d4 you might also
instead of the pawn taking first here on
d4 the knight could come over here to c6
first a lot of times these are all going
to kind of go into this same place end
up in the same variation but you know
from here all White's going to do is
continue with the same thing is bringing
his knight here to f3 this is again this
is a very very important square for this
Knight you know you see this typically
the knight come in to f3 but in this
case particularly it's really defending
all the critical squares early on into
the game so from here doesn't really
matter it you know if the the pawn takes
right here if not white kit 2 can
continue to develop you can always bring
his Bishop it involved into the game he
can pin down this knight if he wants to
castle on the keening side but again
once this pawn takes all what has to do
is take back these really gaining a
strong center of the board so again this
is what happens from the very beginning
if the knight comes down to f6 next
variation we're going to be going is if
the pawn goes to d5 now for a long time
it was thought that pawn to d5 from
black was kind of the go-to move that
kind of fell out of favor and again it
was that Knight to f6 being the main
line this was kind of the secondary move
that people kind of try to bring back
but from here whites just going to
exchange
on d5 so it's going to take with this
pawn here then the queen is going to
come down to d5 and take now why it's
just going to continue to push forward
again he wants to gain control of that
d4 square common theme take all the
initiative back and gain control this d4
score and he does that you can just play
pawn to d4 again if white takes White's
just going to retake with his pawn right
here
if black wanted to he could always you
know try to develop his knight he could
bring his knight here to f6 white could
bring his knight here to f3 again trying
to gain control of this d4 square right
here doesn't really matter where blacks
going I do want to go over one another
thing that you a lot of times see in the
ala pin variation so we'll go ahead and
bring the knight here to c6 one one
thing that you'll see is that this night
right here typically this night will
come to c3
that as far as simple development move
from white you'll see that in a lot of
variations throughout chess in alle pin
variation it's a little bit different
because as you can tell we move our pawn
to c3 early on which you know is a
slight disadvantage because you would
like to control the center of the board
with your knight especially early on so
you have one of two options one is if
you're dark square Bishop comes out into
the game once he's out you can now bring
your knight - let's say d2 if you need
to you got to make sure this is the
right time but another idea that you
always have is bring your knight
initially to a3 now later on to the game
you definitely want that night to be in
the center of the board but you can
always bring your knight to a3 and then
if you wanted to you could bring you
know your Bishop to c4 it's again
protected by that night and that's
really controlling the center of the
board and putting a lot of pressure you
know on this f7 squared which is a
weakness for black early on and then it
allows white to castle on the King side
and further his development now you
again you don't want to leave your
knight here on a three but as far as
initially getting getting him involved
into the game bringing your knight to a3
is not a bad move another variation that
you may see from black is just pawn to
e6 now again why it's going to continue
and he's going to start just pushing
forward with pawn to d4
and black has two options one he could
just take if he exchanges right here
White's just going to recapture with his
pawn again trying to control this d4
square but also trying to control the
center of the board with his pawns
definitely has the upper hand right now
as far as initiative from here black has
a few options if he wants to go ahead
and get his Knights involved into the
game he can you know the knight could
come to c6 and then white could respond
with Knight to f3 if black decides
instead he could bring his pawn down to
d5 and then y can go ahead and exchange
right here and then he can go ahead and
develop let's say he could develop his
knight here - you know c3 putting
pressure on this pawn to d5 now again
this kind of goes along the lines of
what we talked about taking the
initiative back from black from the
Sicilian defense any of the sharp
variation lines from the Sicilian
defense do not look like this with all
of blacks pieces back here on the a
throw so this again this is really
getting your opponent out of their
comfort zone now he doesn't again have
to bring his pawn down to d5 he could
play another move he could get his
Bishop involved into the game he could
bring his Bishop down here to b4 and you
could either block it you know with
Knight to c3
you could always you know place your
Bishop or he could always get his
another Knight involved into the game to
f6 attacking this pawn the pawn can now
come to e5 chasing it away or the knight
could just come here to see three simple
develop move and also protecting this
pawn here on e4 so White has a lot of
the initiative and again this looks very
different from a typical Sicilian
another move you may see from black is
pawn to d6 and again why it's going to
continue with the same theme and that's
pushing forward with pawn to d4 again
trying to control this d4 square right
here now black has a few options if he
wanted to he could always take with this
pawn right here at d4 and then after
white takes Y it's going to have a huge
advantage right here it doesn't really
matter where black goes if he wants to
go ahead and bring you know his knight
to f6 white can just continue to develop
he can bring you know his knight
here to see three if black instead
decided to bring his pawn to e5 pushing
forward and you know put a little
pressure here like and just play you
know Knight to f3 development moves
Center control but white just has a lot
more initiative right here so I
definitely want to be a very very strong
game for black now black also has the
ability to instead of playing pawn takes
here on d4 he could instead bring his
knight over here to f6 now there's a
little variation difference here instead
of you know bringing your knight
involved into the game we don't want to
bring our knight yet to f3 because our
pawn right here on e4 is being attacked
in this case all we have to do is bring
our Bishop to d3 we definitely want to
make sure our LightSquared bishop is
developed in the game so this is not a
bad thing at all and then from here
doesn't really matter once you know if
the knight comes here to c6 putting more
pressure on this pawn to d4 now white
can go ahead and play Knight to f3
simple develop move controlling the
center of the board most importantly in
this opening defending and protecting
this pawn here in the square here on d4
and now if white wanted to later on he
can go ahead and castle on the King side
and then continue moving into the middle
game so again another variation and this
again does not look anything like the
Sicilian defense so we're going to be
going over one more variation the last
variation that we're going to be going
over with is pawn to e5 so basically
white knows that he wants to go ahead
and try to control this d4 square and so
if black wants to double wammy put both
of his pawns here on c5 and e5 and try
to stop you from putting your pawn here
on d4 he definitely may just do this so
pawn to e5 from here what's going to
play a little bit differently typically
white just pushes forward with pawn to
d4 it's not going to do that right away
instead he's going to play his Knight to
f3 attacking this pawn here on e5 that's
trying to control this d4 square right
here so black has a decision to make as
far as how he's going to protect the
most logical place you know definitely
doesn't want to bring its bishop here to
d6 because that blocks off
this pond can't really move which makes
it harder for this LightSquared bishop
to get involved into the game so
typically again minor pieces are meant
to be developed controlled assuming the
board and also protect your pawns
so from here you'll see Knight to c6
simple development move controlling and
defending this pawn here on EE 5 so
white really can't do anything but white
can now play Bishop to c4 again kind of
allowing you know an aggressive move
from white here putting a lot of
pressure again on this f7 Square which
is a huge weakness for black early on
into the game now depending on where
black goes let's say black develops his
other Knight into the game to f6 putting
pressure on this pawn on e4 black white
typically would like to bring his Knight
to c3 nice central square again
defending this pawn here on e4 but again
as we've said in the Oliphant variation
the knight cannot come here to c3
because we have our pawn here so what's
white to do he has a nice little move of
Knight to g5 what this does it's twofold
one it defends this pawn here on e4 from
this night here on f6 but it also does a
double attack on this pawn on f7 again
the s7 square early on is very weak
because the only thing protecting it is
the king now again white now has its
light square bishop aimed at this f7
Square and his knight he can always if
he wants to get his queen involved into
the game if this Knight wasn't there on
f6 he could bring his Queen here to h5
he could always bring it to f3 putting
more pressure on this f7 Square this is
going to be a very very good game from
white he has all the initiative he's
taking that away and then later on once
he's removed this defender then he can
proceed and he can start pushing forward
with pawn to d4 and control that as well
so the ala pin variation again it's a
very very strong opening anytime you
have an opponent that really enjoys
playing the Sicilian defense I recommend
trying this out just to kind of get your
opponent out of their comfort zone so
there's not a lot of tricks and traps
and lots of variations that are just
crazy with
sharp tactical lines but what this does
do is it gets you into the middle game
with a spatial advantage again you have
the initiative so if you're a strong you
know chess player and you kind of like
to get into the middle game with the
advantage kind of getting get that into
the endgame so you can kind of outplay
your opponent I definitely recommend
this because again Sicilian defense your
opponent is trying to take that away
from you so check this out let me know
what you guys think and I'll see you
guys in the next video thanks for
watching